a very State Target yesu shows us what
remains of his home after floods and
landslides devastated northern and
western Rwanda in early May
more than 100 people were killed and
thousands displaced
to aguirayasu says he has never seen
such intense flooding
we walk up to water in the house I live
with my family I had rooms that I rented
out they were destroyed or damaged by
the water those rentals were my
livelihood
known for its Rolling Hills which are
susceptible to landslides during the
rainy season
but people here say these are the worst
in recent years the siber river burst
its banks after the highest rainfall
recorded in the region in 17 years
people say they were sleeping when the
water came many of them could not save
themselves thousands are now living in
shelters that have been provided by the
government
authorities want to relocate tens of
thousands of families from Landslide
prone areas including neighborhoods on
the outskirts of the capital Kigali
but this is a long-term plan and finding
somewhere to move them is a challenge in
the densely populated country there are
people that are directly affected
including those one that are here uh
whose houses are destroyed or damaged
but there are also some others that are
not
affected directly but we
predict that it's going to be a problem
if they stayed
some rhubavu residents are preparing to
rebuild their homes
I had a six bedroom house it was
completely destroyed I'm using the mud
that came with the flood waters to make
bricks for a new home I hope the
government finds alternative land
quickly so we can move
authorities say the priority is to make
sure people still living in danger zones
find homes and quickly
Catherine soy Al Jazeera rubavu Western
Ronda